dear fellow scholars this is two minute
papers with károly janessa here today we
are going to talk about explosions to be
precise
imagine that we already have the physics
simulation data for an explosion on our
computer but we would like to visualize
it on our screen this requires a light
simulation program that is able to
create an image of this virtual scene
that looks exactly the same as it was in
reality we have had plenty of earlier
episodes on light transport and as you
know all too well it is one of my
favorite topics I just can't get enough
of it I've put a link to these related
episodes in the video description if we
wish to render a huge smoke plume we
perform something that computer graphics
people call volumetric light transport
this means that a ray of light doesn't
necessarily bounce off of the surface of
materials but it can penetrate their
surfaces and scatter around inside of
them a technique that can deal with this
is called volumetric path tracing and if
we wish to create an image of an
explosion using that well better pack
some fast food because it is likely
going to take several hours the
explosion in this image took 13 hours
and it is still not rendered perfectly
but this technique is able to solve this
problem
in 20 minutes which is almost 40 times
quicker unbelievable the key idea is
that this super complicated volumetric
explosion data can be reimagined as a
large batch of point light sources if we
solve this light transport problem
between these point light sources we get
a solution that is remarkably similar to
the original solution with path tracing
however solving this new representation
is much simpler but that's only the
first step if we have a bunch of light
sources we can create a grid structure
around them and in these grid points we
can compute shadows and illumination in
a highly efficient manner what's more we
can create multiple of these great
representations they all work on the
very same data with some of them are
finer and some of them are significantly
sparser more coarse another smart
observation here is that even those
sharp high-frequency illumination
details need to be computed on this fine
grid which takes quite a bit of
computation time it is
to solve the course low-frequency
details on one of these sparse circuits
the results look indistinguishable from
the ground truth solutions but the
overall computation time is
significantly reduced the paper contains
detailed comparisons against other
techniques as well most of these scenes
are rendered using hundreds of thousands
of these point light sources and as you
can see the results are unbelievable if
you would like to learn even more about
light transport I am holding a master
level course on this at the Vienna
University of Technology in Austria I
thought that the teaching should not
only be available for those thirty
people who sit in the room who can
afford a university education it should
be available for everyone so we made the
entirety of the lecture available for
everyone free of charge and I am so glad
to see that thousands of people have
watched it and to this day I get many
messages that they enjoyed it and now
they see the world differently it was
recorded live with the students in the
room and it doesn't have the audio
quality of two minute papers however
what it does well is it conjures up the
atmosphere of these lectures and you can
almost feel like one of the students
sitting there if you are interested have
a look the link is available in the
video description and make sure to read
this paper too it's incredible thanks
for watching and for your generous
support and I'll see you next time
[Music]
you